well then there's Foucault Foucault
whoo-hoo I have no respect for by the
way I think I think I've read if they're
a bit offical and I think everything he
says is obvious so for example he
criticizes the idea of mental illness as
a as a social construct it's like well
yeah
obviously I mean it's not like
psychiatrists and psychologists and
mental health professionals who are
relatively well-informed haven't known
about that since for the last 60 years I
mean it might be a revelation to people
who who don't notice that psyche
psychiatry for example is something like
a compromise between the patient biology
and the social world you know I mean
psychiatric ailments often have a
biological tilt but the way they
manifest themselves in society is
clearly conditioned in very intense ways
by that particular conditions obtaining
at the point that the person who has
that biological predisposition exists
even whether or not that's pathological
can be tilted one way or another by the
by cultural norms and then of course
when you're dealing with issues like
insurance payment and treatment and
hospitalization obviously you're pulling
in all sorts of systems that are by no
means purely scientific but I don't find
it a particularly useful critique it's
obvious as far as I'm concerned and the
other thing that Foucault did I mean I
think this is the typical especially the
French intellectuals typical sleight of
hand once Marxism became you know once
you were no longer able to call yourself
a committed Marxist because committed
Marxism had led to unbelievable
brutality you know on a scale that had
never probably I think never been
experienced in the entire history of the
planet at least in terms of his reach
and duration you didn't get to call
yourself a Marxist anymore although
there were still people and you still
see them saying well that wasn't real
Marxism which i think is a cop-out of
staggering proportions it usually means
well if I was the person running the
country that wouldn't have happened you
know that's the logic behind it
they didn't put the principles into
practice properly it's like yeah well
lots of people put the damn principles
into practice and the same thing
happened everywhere so at some point you
have to kind of wonder if there's
something wrong with the principles
anyways what Foucault did was take the
Marxist presupposition that everything
was could be boiled down to economics
and economic power and translated it
into the idea that everything just
boiled down to power you know and that
the reason that we have institutions is
to include and to exclude and that the
institutions always run for the benefit
of those at the top it's like well yeah
that's a little bit true but it's you
know it's it's a scientist would look at
that and say yeah well probably you know
power dynamics in a in a functioning
economic and political system maybe
account for 10% of the variance
something like that maybe 15% so for
example if you have a say you want to go
to an Ivy League school well if your
parents went to the school you're more
likely to get in but you're not that
much more likely to get in and you still
have to be you know roughly speaking
what happens is that if you have a
pretty decent you know high school GPA
and you do very well on the SATs and you
have some other talents of some sort
because that's also necessary then they
might pick you over someone else who's
roughly equally qualified if you have a
familial history of attendance at the
school so obviously you get an exact and
an advantage but it's not it's not the
kind of advantage that accounts for the
entirety of how the system is structured
it's an advantage well you can say well
that's not fair it's like yeah okay fair
enough most systems are certainly not a
hundred percent either fair or just
definitely not mmm-hmm but you know
instead of comparing them to utopia you
might compare them to another system
which is the only reasonable way to do
it it's like everything looks
parable when you compare it to the best
thing you can possibly imagine but the
best thing you can possibly imagine is
it's an empty fiction because it's so
devoid of detailed content that you
can't use it as a guide to reality now I
mean the idea that things could be
better has its roots in in some sense in
a broad scale utopian project and I
believe that things could be better but
that doesn't mean that when you're doing
an analysis of a complex system you get
to compare it to an ideological utopia
and then describe all the reasons that
it's bad it's not appropriate to do that
it's it's too simplistic you're not
going to do anything to actually address
the problems that the system has if you
take that approach and then of course
like purely utopian thinking is
extraordinarily dangerous because if you
think that your way of molding society
into some ultimate state of perfection
is headed towards some ultimate stated
perfection then you can justify
absolutely anything you do right now on
the basis of the fact that things are
going to improve so radically in the
future and that means any of your
behaviors are excused the end is worth
it well if someone says that you have to
kind of wonder what there are actually
planning excuse me what they're actually
planning to do so okay so well what's
the issue well the issue is that it's so
the same critic with regards to Foucault
he said you know what's basically the
same thing that Foucault criticized a
variety of low you know profound
institutions sexual institutions say
like marriage and then institutions of
power like prisons and institutions of
mental health
you know the whole institutional
framework he criticized them on the
basis of power and exclusion and you
could do that and there's some truth in
it
but you know Foucault also made the
presupposition the problem with that
presupposition is that everything is
about seven something else is that it's
almost impossible to see how it can't be
applied to Foucault himself so you'd
have to ask if you were a student of
Foucault what power aims drove his
attempt to analyze everything in terms
of power and I actually think with
Foucault it's pretty obvious so but it's
a game that never goes anywhere